raw foodists are romantics very often or
sometimes there's practical people who
discovered a way to make themselves feel
better I a common reason for eating raw
food is that people find that they have
reduced symptoms of allergic reaction
and it looks as though some people are
simply allergic to some of the
consequences of cooking so if you
discover that and you eat raw you'll
feel a lot better some people do it for
philosophical reasons that you know we
we are animals animals eat their food
raw so we ought to feed our food raw as
I say I i think is wrong because think
we are the animals that have evolved to
eat our food cooked I'm I'm full of
admiration for raw foodist because it's
an incredibly difficult thing to do I
mean particularly when people start they
describe how much of a struggle it is
not to go out and get so you know a
candy bar some bread some pizza whatever
it is and it's a very awkward way to eat
because it takes for a long time to
prepare your food you have to eat a lot
because be you're basically hungry all
the time and so it interferes with your
social life raw food is tend to hang out
with raw foodists it changes a lot about
your life but for those people who find
it works for them it clearly works
really really well and there are a lot
of us who would like to emulate this
because it's a great way to lose weight
you know it's the ultimate way to
control your own body
yeah the way to a mans how does her
stomach and all that sort of thing I
don't know I mean there's a funny thing
because people have long noted that that
cooking is is very sociable we we like
to eat with each other around the fire
we like to to bring the food out of the
oven together and he does a meal and yet
there is no simple logical reason
there's no so technical reason why that
should be it's perfectly possible for an
individual to cook for themselves alone
for years as the model for Robinson
Crusoe did Alexander Selkirk in living
alone on a tropical island for years and
we could all be doing that in in theory
why we do it nowadays well I'm sure
there's lots of cultural history to that
but I'm kind of interested in the
question of of why it starts why the
pattern of people congregating in the
evening to share the evening meal why
does that happen in hunters and
gatherers and small scales open-air
societies and there I think one can make
a reasonable answer that it derives
ultimately from something a little bit
competitive and that is that anybody who
cooks is giving a clear signal to
everyone else that there is going to be
food ready fairly soon and they end up
being vulnerable to the hungry and the
lazy and the scroungers who for one
reason or another don't have any food of
their own and want to to take some and
the short story I think is that the
tendency for us all to congregate and
eat meals together represents the
outcome of a system of social regulation
which is ultimately designed to protect
those who are producing the food and I
think the way it works ultimately is
that the women end up producing the food
there are men who could take it and what
happens is that women marry and the
husband is functionally among his other
very important functions
he is there to protect her food from
some lousy bachelor who comes home was
incredibly hungry and can't resist
taking some food off the fire as soon as
the cooks back is turned and you see
this written up and described in in
small-scale societies the the bachelors
are are thin and they're hungry and
nobody's there to cook for them and they
have a problem and the married men are
superior to them and kind of keep them
down so that's one of the dynamics but
it means that it's great for husbands
and wives sweet together and of course
the children are there and then it can
extend easily to others in the camp and
suddenly were a rosy feeling and and now
now you can afford maybe in a sort of
regulated way to give food out to those
that don't have it
I don't know how the numeration ships
are going or where they will go I just
think there's going to be many fewer
constraints in the future that I think
in the past this has been a major
constraint the fact that you needed to
have somebody in the household cooking
for others and it was the women for I
think reasons because men were able to
get away with it that is increasingly
going to go away and isn't that great
you know we can get away from one
particular source of a sexist unfairness
and I think it heralds a much more
exciting world in which women are able
to participate in the the professions
and the life of the community to a far
greater extent than before